the release of American basketball star
Brittany Greiner who's been held in
Russia on drug charges since February is
Raising new concerns over what can be
described as hostage diplomacy a release
was part of a prisoner swap for
notorious Russian arms dealer Victor
boot who was serving a 25-year sentence
in the U.S but there are questions about
why former U.S marine Paul Whelan who
has been in a Russian prison for four
years was not part of the deal
Christina raffini is at the White House
with the latest on this Christina good
morning to you
good morning Jeff Russian President
Vladimir Putin said this week that he's
not opposed to the idea of future
prisoner swaps he wouldn't rule them out
and of course the families of detained
Americans all over the world want the
U.S to do whatever it can to bring their
loved ones home but lawmakers and law
enforcement are concerned that this
practice could make Americans more of a
Target
it was either Brittany or no one the
White House this week celebrated and
defended the return of WNBA star
Brittany Greiner to American soil this
was about getting getting Brittany home
this is about getting unjustly detained
Americans back to their families that's
that was the focus it's nothing more
it's also nothing less but the prisoner
exchange a one-for-one swap for
international arms dealer Victor boot
did not include American Paul Whelan a
former Marine detained in Russia on
Espionage charges for almost four years
I wish that Paul Whelan had been on that
that plane too we've been doing
everything possible to to bring him out
a U.S official tells CBS news that over
the summer Moscow proposed trading
Whelan for a Russian assassin serving a
life sentence in Germany but the U.S had
no power to release him and Germany
refused hostile weak foreign Nations
taking Americans prisoner and holding
them as hostages this has to stop and my
brother needs to come home on CBS
morning's Elizabeth Whelan said her
brother's captivity is part of a larger
issue in July the state department
started including a d indicator in its
Travel warnings for countries where
Americans could be at higher risk of
wrongful detention including Russia and
China we need to solve this problem not
just for my brother but also for
Americans in general who want to travel
now in that same interview as CBS
secretary blinken said he's working with
a coalition of about 60 other countries
that are looking to end this practice
which is essentially hostage taking for
political purpose he said they're
looking at sanctions Visa bans and other
measures Dana
all right Christina thank you